at conception a sperm carrying either an
x or y chromosome fuses with an egg
which carries an X chromosome in this
process a single cell called a zygote is
formed the combination of chromosomes
inside the cell decides if the baby will
be a boy or a
girl an X and A Y chromosome create a
male and two x a female
around one in 5,000 of us happen to get
a different chromosome combination they
are sometimes referred to as interex and
a proof that something as binary as male
and female can be on a spectrum for
Simplicity we will compare typical men
and
women at Birth children are typically
identified as boys or girls boys tend to
be slightly larger and heavier than
girls their heads are often a bit bigger
too within weeks cultural norms start to
reinforce traditional gender roles this
makes it difficult for scientists to
know what behavioral differences are
biological and which ones are socially
constructed during childhood boys tend
to be more physically active exhibiting
greater interest in objects and
exploration they also begin to have a
better understanding of threedimensional
space girls are less active take a
higher interest in people and seem to
form a better understanding of them they
also learn new languages faster at just
16 months girls on average have a
vocabulary of 95 words more than three
times that of
boys during puberty kids become
teenagers their bodies change and the
differences between boys and girls
become more
obvious around the ages of 8 to 13 girls
start to get taller their body shape
begins to change and hair grows in new
places this continues into their mid to
late teens puberty also brings the start
of their menstrual periods technically
they can now become pregnant give birth
and feed their
baby they also have elevated levels of
the hormone estrogen are highly social
and tend to show more empathy physically
not as strong as their male counterparts
they exhibit a greater capacity to
endure pain and can rival men in Ultra
endurance
runs boys enter puberty a bit later with
a growth spurt that Peaks around age 14
they develop more muscle mass body hair
and a larger Adams Apple which gives
them a deeper voice that can intimidate
some and attract
others boys also produce more
testosterone and develop a higher
aggression potential they are now larger
faster significantly stronger and about
10 times more likely to end up in
jail some teens now identify as a gender
different from the sex assigned to them
at Birth and about 3 to 10% enter their
reproductive years with an interest in
the same sex
during their reproductive years and
until their mid-30s both sexes are
typically very good at making babies but
they face two very different
risks men can technically make a baby in
minutes women however have to invest
many months into pregnancy and give
birth with vast physical and
psychological
consequences this puts them at a lot of
risk if the relationship breaks apart
however they do have one
advantage once the newborn arrives
mothers can be certain that the infant
is theirs a father that loves and cares
for a child risks finding out it is not
his and depending on the culture 1 to
10% do unknowingly raise another man's
child so what's Mama's baby is Papa's
maybe a woman's anxiety about becoming a
mother with no help supporting the
family and a man's spere of paternal
fraud is said to create some very
different concerns about
cheating one Theory hence suggests that
men tend to worry more about sexual
infidelity they want to make sure
they're raising the child they fathered
women typically get more jealous when
they feel emotionally betrayed they
worry that precious family resources are
shared with someone else
in midadulthood men and women begin to
lose some of their ability to make
babies if we study fertility by age we
see that women's fertility drops from
their early 30s and by their 40s chances
of getting pregnant naturally are slim
around their 50s they enter menopause
and their periods stop men remain
reproductive much longer but from age 35
the chance of produc producing a faulty
sperm cell increases exponentially with
each passing
year as they reach late adulthood women
live longer men die about 6 years
younger often because of heart failure
perhaps because they don't care as much
about their health and live a more risky
life what do you think how does sex
differences influence our society and
how does society influence them and
should we create laws and regulations to
purposefully reduce the differences
share your thoughts and comments
below if you like this video and want us
to make more subscribe to our Channel or
support us on
patreon